we are back now at 7 30 with a medical
first to tell you about and this is a
big one surgeons at the university of
maryland medical center have
transplanted the heart of a pig into a
57 year old human being a man doctors
say this man is doing well in those
early and critical days just after this
highly experimental surgery but there
are still a lot of questions about his
future dr taran narula has more on
exactly how this procedure was done
he simply didn't want to die
doesn't want to die
patient david bennett a maryland
handyman and father is awake and
recovering days after a seven hour
surgery to replace his heart with that
of a genetically modified pigs this big
heart has performed so far very well
even beyond our expectations when
bennett arrived at the university of
maryland medical center he was dying and
ineligible for a human transplant
because of the severity of his heart
disease and medical history my dad's
prognosis early on was very very very
bad his son said bennett agreed to the
experimental procedure despite a slim
chance of success
this was his best hope of getting out of
the hospital and having somewhat of a
normal quality of life he says i don't
want to die
and he said if i do
maybe
you'll learn something to help others
although it's too soon to know the
long-term success of the surgery doctors
say it can offer hope to similar
patients there are hundreds and
thousands of people all around the world
who are waiting for the organ and
unfortunately just like this patient may
not qualify for an organ transplant
there have been prior attempts to
transplant an animal organ into a human
including baby fae in 1984 who lived
with a baboon heart for three weeks
but those have failed because the body
rejects the organ rapidly this time the
pig that supplied the heart went through
gene editing to remove cells thought to
be responsible for rejection we're
learning a lot every day with this
gentleman and so far
we're happy with our decision to move
forward and he is as well a big smile on
his face today for cbs mornings i'm dr
tara narula
so this is it's an amazing thing there's
a lot going on though yeah people who
animal rights activists say look we
shouldn't be using animals in this way
but then you also have like bioethicists
medical bioethicists who say this is
outside of a clinical trial that should
have been tested on recently deceased
people rather than a living person uh
but all that aside if this works it's a
game changer i know
yeah i went to university of maryland
feeling very proud of the maryland team
today i like when the doctors say it's
exceeded their expectations that the
patient is awake and recovering let's
hope that continues yeah it is
mind-blowing to think about the medical
advances yeah think about this if we
were having this conversation 50 or 60
years ago you would say you're
absolutely out yeah this will never
happen yeah no doubt about